i'm interested jim and hear your your
tactics to win
this to preempt this civil war because i
think of it as a long-term game with the
chinese you know
an 80-year plan to subvert our culture
by feeding things to our children
so i'm kind of thinking in that same
realm like
i don't want to go head at it because
that's what they want me to do they want
me to come straight at them so they can
ban me for something
you have to do some of that but first of
all i'll say one that one of the first
things you should do make comedy shows
right make our culture popular because
right now
they're the the authoritarian jerks that
nobody likes we're the cool kids
so let's be the cool kids let's make
good movies ben shapiro's people the
daily wire that run hide shoot movie
was a good it was a great movie and not
a great movie by conservatives
it was a great action flick and that
chick was a
can i say bad yeah i could say badass
i don't want to get you thrown out she
was a badass it was a great movie i was
on the edge of my seat
infidel by dinesh d'souza another great
movie not just a great show
conservative yeah oh wow and and it was
it was an action flick
you know jim caviezel in a in a prison
getting rescued
comes in with a helicopter it was bad
ass
your comedy show i guarantee is gonna be
badass because you wouldn't make it
otherwise you're gonna do we got
something
in some of these comics i'm just like oh
these guys they push it so
hard good george carlin that's punk rock
george carlin got arrested for his bit
the seven words you can't say on tv you
gotta be arrested for that
they don't do that today but they'll ban
you it's true to go see george carlin
wow literally i had because we had to
travel far enough to do it that was punk
rock
yeah but that's just it that's the first
thing you do is create
things that aren't woke but are cool all
right because that's the thing the right
has always been
uptight well what's up tight is statists
telling you how to live your life
so what's the antidote to that liberty
loving people who are cool and having a
good time you wanna know something crazy
this is this is this kind of this kind
of pisses me off uh
so a lot of people most people know i've
been skateboarding for several decades
and uh i've i know a bunch of pro
skateboarders
and they won't they don't want to come
they don't want to come and film
segments they don't want to come and
skate the ramp they're scared you know
why
skateboarding is mainstream culture it
is corporate
and it is while not the biggest industry
in the world and not the wealthiest and
not the most mainstream
during the olympics baby they got big
brand sponsors they do big multi-million
dollar events so i'm like i'm talking to
this guy
i love your show i love what you do and
i was like you want to come from a
segment they're like dude i just
we can't get a target on us i get i get
all i get the other
the the other action sports i can call
it we have one dude who is like i'm a
you know bmx writer i'm gonna come to
the film segment i'm like okay it looks
like we're gonna do bmx
this guy this guy made this youtube
video i want to come and do some tail
whips in your park and i'm like
let's make it happen now we're gonna put
up videos on the website these ones will
be free and we'll share like here's a
dude
you know we're we what i want to do with
this with the space we have because we
have something we call the grind bar
we set up the skate park in the in the
garage it's big and you can actually
ollie up
onto a ledge and then ollie onto the bar
which jump up on okay i should just say
jump because it could be any sport
but you can grind across the bar itself
so we're going to film these challenges
and we're going to have fun and be punk
rock and play music and i got to say
it's
hard to get the skateboarders to do it
because their sponsors are big
mainstream corporations
the smaller less popular action sports
no offense to
inline skaters or to bmxers they don't
got nearly as many followers or big
sponsors so they're like dude i'm
totally down when i was young i used to
always want i chased the people that had
already made it because i was like if i
can get those people to join me
then it's gonna be big and then i
realized nah man i'm just going to make
it
and all the people that want to make it
with me are they going to be the people
that in the future have made it
yeah build build our culture you know
and
don't rely on other people to do it
because you can't you can rely on them
trying to kill it
so assume that you have a target on you
already
and build mechanisms to get your message
out and get your entertainment out and
get your views out
that they can't take away from you like
your own website which is another thing
too i hope it's hosted on a boat
somewhere
in the north atlantic so that amazon
can't shut you down well that's the
other thing too is we're talking about
creating this open source project
to create a uh subscription-based
service that anyone could have on their
own website
yes people contact me on twitter direct
message if you want to get involved with
that it's very cool we're setting up a
chat room right now through the matrix
protocol it's going to be an open source
project yeah and so
the idea is you got a website all you
got to do is install the simple open
source package and then people can
become members to your site but all the
sites network with each other so
basically we create a decentralized
network of independent websites
that's exactly how the soviet union went
down they just did it with paper
salmon right that was people passing
information back amongst themselves
underneath the web of the status masters
yeah now the other thing you talked
about the long war the long wars
education
all right we're dead unless we have an
alternative way
to make sure our kids don't get taught
that america's evil that freedom is bad
you know and that they have to believe
the woke bible so you got to work
on that you know and that's that's a
long-term project that's a generational
war
they've been at it for several
generations that's why we've got the
problems we do
so you got to do that you got to stand
up for free speech
all right so you got to do three things
you got to get the education your free
speech and you have to have popular
culture
right which are the things they took
away from us i used to think internet
video alone would be enough to educate
people that they would the information's
there
so they will find it but now i'm finding
it's guided you know people are guided
towards especially with alg social media
algorithms people are being guided
towards specific types of information
but yeah you can set up your own for for
schools though
i i do wonder how many of these kids in
schools are hearing their teacher say
you want to be a woke anti-racist and
these students are going wow
i want to be just like teacher i can't
imagine there's a lot of kids who are
like that
that's the other thing people are not
paying attention to is is the pendulum
swings back and forth that you rebel
against authority who's the authority
now the status authoritarians
right what what do kids hate more than
anything being told what they have to do
right so we're going to see that that's
what we need to take advantage of that's
available
what's what's past gen z millennial jen
double z
gen zed zed i don't know hey i
incidentally i'm staking a claim
jen a1 no i am the lead dog of gen
x all right oh nice the people claim
this 1965 is october 1964
because i am the first member of gen x
and my crew is in power now
and we invented all the sports that are
now lame you know all the skydiving and
skateboard flips that are crazy stuff
that are now lamely corporate oh the
sports aren't like no but the
corporatism of them is
but we invented that because we rebelled
i was thinking about how crazy this is
though because i was i was i was
listening to tony hawk talk about being
a skateboarder and how hard it was
in the 80s you were a loser yeah you
were weirdos doing this thing nobody was
you're supposed to play football or
basketball or baseball because
now sports now it's the olympics now
it's it's red bull and these big
corporations
even even a lot of snowboarding too it's
just it's surprising to me how
boring it's become for real because it's
not dangerous anymore because it's
become corporatized
right and that's good and now now that
those people are scared let's pick
other ones pick a new sport you know
there's some crazy thing pick airsoft
you know you know
i saw your guns and i figured your
airsoft airsoft yeah i thought it was
interesting because there was uh there
are some pros who are like
some people will always complain about
the changing culture of everything
and there are a lot of people who say
skateboarding was better back in the day
and you know to them i would say it just
changed and for kids who are growing up
in today are going to be very happy with
skateboarding and
that's true i'm just talking about
towing the line i'm talking about pros
who used to be like i'm going to go
skate this bank where you literally you
can get arrested for being on private
property
now it's a lot of park now you've got
like the olympics
are are coming up and so there's this
big competition anyone in the united
states apparently can enter by
submitting a 45 second run
in a you know it doesn't have to be in a
park but it needs to incorporate park
terrain
basically this means everyone's going to
be in a skate park skating
whereas skateboarding for for the
longest time was being out in the
streets and conquering terrain urban
terrain
it was almost urban exploration in a
sense yeah but that was
vandalism you know it was it was punk
rock you were going out you were telling
the security guards to eff i'm not a fan
of that by the way
you're supposed to leave and then come
back later you don't you know fight with
people
uh because people get hurt but you'd
like put wax on a ledge in front of a
building
it a long term it would scuff it up and
discolor it but they didn't care
it wasn't your property they didn't care
it was punk rock it was edgy it was
disrespectful in other ways
it's there's still a bit of that street
skating culture but it's become very
corporate
and it's like yeah it's not really
interesting to be another cog in the
giant machine
i just i i think it's it's time to
create new ideas new cultures new
concepts maybe airsoft is the thing we
should be filming
video gaming is one that used to be so
nerdy
and uncool like in the 80s i was the
they called me nintendo crossland in
elementary school and i was like the
dork but like now people are
multi-millionaire
superstars gaming giant
you know i mean it's it's one of the
biggest industries in the world and i
think it's just gonna get cooler and
then it'll eventually it has kind of
been corporatized you know amazon owns
twitch
and it's kind of dictating what people
can say but man there are some punk rock
if you watch gamers stream the things
they will say
like if you want to tap into the child's
psyche
you know twitch sent me an email because
i've got an account everywhere because i
have to
and they literally said this is the new
things we're going to de-platform people
that happen off twitch yep i got that
too
i'm social credit scoring dude exactly
and that's that's where
these people will rebel so we have the
ability to go ahead and appeal to people
who don't like to be told what to do
which is basic libertarianism you know
it's not a governing philosophy
but it's a personal philosophy and you
can tell those people if you want to be
left alone to enjoy your life
you should be hanging out with us
because if you hang out with the world
crew
though you can't ever get the rules
right what rules how you ever gonna
follow
all the rules of wokeness because they
change every time
someone else pops up and one of the
rules is we can ban you at any time for
no reason
literally for no reason at any time who
wants to play with that game that's
that's ridiculous
garbage go look for my twitter feed and
i'm not there because
i say things that they don't like and i
kick their butts you know and and that's
that's pathetic so
let's appeal to the people who don't
like that and here's the nice thing the
the woke people are helping us
because look at what's happening with
blacks and latinos from the last
election
all right people talk about we got
killed in the election we picked up 12
house seats for the republicans and more
black and latino votes than
ever before for trump of all people they
said he was a racist
exactly now why is that it's because
they watched those riots and everything
last year and those are working class
people
who have jobs they lost their jobs
because of kovid
when the when the democrats locked them
down and they
businesses were burnt down by blm and
antifa
and that made them mad and they're like
where are the or the police
why aren't the police coming to help me
right i thought they were the good guys
like no
no defund the police the police are evil
police you hate the police like i don't
hate the police i hate criminals i hate
gangs
i gotta pull up this chart i love
pulling this [ __ ] this chart up oh yeah
before
the george floyd riots black lives
matter enjoyed 17
net support in this country after
uh the george floyd incident it spiked
23
net support something then happened do
you know what happened as you know right
after this the spark of the george
floyd's story what happened in this
country
what what did people start doing no no
no no what was the direct response
to the death of george floyd among them
bought guns no riots yeah okay
they started going around bernie sanders
and then everyone else bought guns down
the house
the net support then dropped to seven
percent
currently today net support for black
lives matter is at six
percent a year out you get it it is
almost
it is it is 40 i believe let's see let's
uh let's go back to the beginning of
last year was it around
not it was eight nine percent so it's
down between you know
20 to 35 percent net support it's made
me feel good man
that's that's wonderful news because
they're a recruiter for our team they're
a recruiter for the team that likes
freedom and liberty
not a bunch of angry racists
telling us that the rest of us are
racist don't project on to me
and tell me how to live my life
beautiful let's let's uh
i'll be sure to yeah like don't mess
with your enemy while they're making a
mistake
exactly yeah and they're going to do it
again i kind of feel for this black
lives matter movement in a way because i
feel like antifa
got their tentacles all wrapped up in it
and did a lot of violence just like
angry violent anarchists just kind of
used that movement
and got involved in a way that wasn't
the intention
from the beginning of that not that i
was i was there at some of the first
black lives matter protests it was
always the same people
antifa for the most part is just the
flag they use
it's far leftists of various persuasions
who wear all black and go around
engaging in violence
and before we called them antifa we just
called them the black bloc
it was a reference to the same leftist
protesters activists extremists we've
always known
and when i was in new york at the
trayvon martin protest they were there
as well
the same people now fly the antifa flag
same people
and then and the black lives matter
protest no matter how well-intentioned
some of them may be
you've always got the young angry crowd
that wants to break stuff
and so those two groups would meld
together and they create like the ball
of
ugliness and somebody would break a
window and then it's gone
from there but the the bad part is and i
think the good thing for us
is that they now have busted their brand
their brand is violence now it's working
in intimidating local leaders but it's
not working and gaining public support
it's pushing normals toward us the
working class normal people
now i think that's an interesting
coalition i just outlined we've got
the punk rock radical cool kids now
hanging out with the normal working
class folks
but we're all the ones who say we know
how to live our lives you don't tell us
how to live our lives
and we'll take care of business i love
cryptocurrency because it's so punk rock
and like
internet developers so punk rock like
they are
building the future cool i'm in
yeah no guarantees but this is it's a
big reason why a lot of
anarchists bought into bitcoin very
early on oh yeah not leftian or kiss
because they don't believe in money i
guess
but all the right anarchists got super
rich they were like it's money the
government doesn't know about i'll buy
it all
smart and then they they went ahead and
created a new way to do business which
we're allowed to do
and again to your point of let's create
shows and let's do other things
and new sports and other things that
popularize what we're doing from our
side
and guess what we are going to be much
more entertaining
and inviting than the other side because
you can tell they're angry because we
have human they're unpleasant
we can tell jokes we mock people and
it's fun
you know but we but it's it's like
insulting and disparaging people for the
sake of being mean is not fun
but playfully ripping at each other over
you know stereotypes and other dumb
ideas is fun it's fun and funny
because we're all part of the same jokes
we're all being made fun of we're all on
on a level playing field with each other
so could we have stand-up comedy back
then
could we literally because they've
killed that dude for authentic purposes
ryan long though
he's amazing he's he's nailing it but
what's he doing he's mocking woke
culture
he's found he's found the magic bullet
but he's got he's
you know these videos he makes often do
most of the time but he also
has a stand-up routine he has a bunch of
other jokes uh i think he recently did
a joke about the nsa watching watching
dudes whack off
like he's not making fun of the woke
he's just a funny guy he's a funny dude
and he and he makes fun of the woke and
it's funny too and there that's the nice
thing
is when you can mock your enemy you hurt
them more
than you ever can with any kind of
violence or anger or anything else
you you delegitimize them because you
don't take them seriously
and they're they're so good you know
they mock themselves you can't you can't
hardly caricature
he does and he does it well but that's
just it they are so
absurd that and there's so much ammo
there that if more people take that up
guess what you've got now we need a
daily show
from the right yeah you know looking at
the bible yeah
yeah you get crowded yeah every morning
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you